a minha voz misteriosa é é
e na capa essa é a minha vida todos os
dias é que faz os aqui não me lembras o
lábio todos pessoal quem fala aqui sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo depois
de muito tempo sem postar nada porque
tudo teve um motivo ok eu vou explicar
aqui neste vídeo depois desse tempo todo
nós entretanto mudamos de casa e o iupi
e o nosso amigos o que é tão bem a
pessoa que vocês mais querem ver
revelado aqui neste canal é voz
misteriosa voz misteriosa está aqui em
casa e eu vou regular hoje aqui no vídeo
como vocês poderão ver pelo título então
vai tão fofinho este cão podem ver o
suco está a adorar a casa o nome para de
mandar beijinhos aí está super contente
mas hoje pessoal hoje nós temos ali a
nossa voz misteriosa ajudar mas eu não
vou mostrar eram extra já vamos usar
muito tempo que não costumo fazer este
tipo de vídeos né tipo vlog assim e
mostrar como é que está a correr a minha
vida e talvez
o que fazer isso porque eu quero mostrar
aqui o novo espaço que era irregular
também a voz misteriosa que é que vocês
fazem conhecer a minha namorada ok então
vai ser tudo revelado aqui neste vídeo
todos os aparelhos que eu tenho a dar
vai ser tudo neste vídeo que portanto
parte nenhum vídeo com os vossos amigos
aquele vinho lá no whatsapp não digo
nada só para tirei lá deixa muito like
aqui neste vídeo e bora lá então ao que
interessa regular aqui a casa revelar a
voz misteriosa e vamos mostrar aqui um
pouquinho como está a ser a nossa vida
com esta mudança de toda né porque isso
atrapalha sempre um pouco a nossa vida é
caixas e fica qual é arrumações do
comedor de costa que nem entretanto
também tô aqui a gravar com uma câmera
nova mais leve portanto ficar bem podre
imagem é porque eu estou a fazer testes
ok mas acho que em princípio está tudo
ok olha aí olha aí nos melhores e nos
ganha um salário duplo queixo ainda tem
apoio do emagrecer um pouquinho mas
ainda tá aqui do bloqueio enfim é assim
este vai aos pouquinhos eu te atender
porque aquilo que está
o homem estava escondido
e o pintado ali escondido enquanto
estava a fazer o vídeo meu deus bora lá
pessoal deixa muito like aqui neste
vídeo vamos tentar chegar aos 50.000
likes que é uma coisa que já não
acontece há algum tempo ok conto com
vocês faz misteriosa estás pronta como
sempre ela está toda contente ainda nem
apareceu hoje já tá tudo é confiante o
meu deus e a voz misteriosa é não é
e tu tás a fazer na escada tá
o que você achou doentes vai faz latulia
dessa presta à população
e aí
e eu aprendi a dançar nos anos 80 mas tu
tem 19 anos isso é mentira eu tenho mil
e tal eu sou convida a dança da voz
misteriosa em
a caixa misteriosa fala um pouco sobre
ti eu tenho 19 anos eu gosto de longos
passeios pela praia surfar junto terror
gosto de comida gosto de chocolate e
gosta de ti ai que bonito o olho olha
mas houve um vídeo que me filmar que não
estavas a tratarmos a é brincar pessoas
acharam todas rude arrogant olha o teu
cheiro cola também arruda e não não sei
muito bem o teu chega ocorre rivel
horrível nascer mobile o que é
e não não isso é calúnia isso é calúnia
não não é tudo mentira é tudo o meu
composta muito bem não eu sempre um
e tu vais ao pé daqui eu vou lá para
cima que é para me proteger de ser
comece logo a fazer lá então falar
depois meu era verdade ok ok ok este
vídeo não é sobre o país ok vamos falar
de coisas interessantes então neste
momento estou aqui com a voz misteriosa
e o pin nesta casa e a voz misteriosa
vamos apresentar então é nova casinha
para você já que ela tem tanto talento a
fazer vídeos não é e tentavam foste tu
que disseste inclusive alguém prometeu
fazer uma sobremesa hoje eu não disse
que eu fiz já fiz um bolo ó eu vou
mostrar aqui eu vou mostrar aqui o bolo
quem fez ou está bem vazio porque temos
em mudanças mas o que fez este bolo aqui
tubarão fatia mas está o bolo uma mulher
bem mais isso galera acabou símbolo é
maior trato a lição sobre esta fatia e
tu prometeste fazer a tua isso não é uma
fatia isso é um pai três quando acabar o
bolo eu posso obrigar a comer essa
simpatia não é
é mas não é uma fatia só vai voltar aqui
olha só para ti vais comer ela hoje e
amanhã vai fazer sobremesa tu vou
começar aqui pelo meu melhor amigo o
anãozinho que é que lindo e maravilhoso
sabe que ser uma boneca amarelo com
experiências era exatamente a
personalidade aqui temos a nossa vitrina
com figuras que eu organizei não é por
nada não está muito bonita e
o que causa um dos dias mas é boa só que
não faz mal olha aqui está o homem
unicórnio playstation olha o frigorífico
que não tem nada lá dentro ainda não tem
nada nós estamos a pensar na encher isto
tudo com monstros e com bebidas porque
esta vai ser a zona onde nós temos a
pensarem em que mesmo para nós estamos
aqui
se ouvirmos os vinyls gusttavo lima
máquina de uma máquina de máquina o
leitor de mil um gira-discos eu vou
fazer muito velho eu nem sei que isso é
um gira-discos é muito
i wear temos aqui dias que o livro e
essa é a zona basicamente da rodovia os
música nessa não mais fiz tenho este
venda sofá ah pois é mas que falta aqui
as vidas ou uso que já quero também os
aqui tá triste porque ele não tem
dúvidas temos que buscar a insurgente e
para de lamber os tomates não não a
minha frente não ai o menino ai tomar um
bocado
tu estás estás bem aqui horas esta assim
ciências da natureza mas não tava lá
fora está dentro isso é falso não
importa não é esta casa de banho
e tem a minha amiga patrícia
e ela ela tava normal que é isso porque
é que existe na casa de banho parece que
o que eu uso aqui pela foi posto eu
também tava juro eu juro eu juro eu juro
eu vi eu vi os meus olhos e eu acho que
ela apareceu aqui sozinha não não eu
acabei de tomar banho não não é
[Música]
e não todos os cristão limpar é
ou para livro suzuki sei o que é
e aqui ó uma zona restrita
e ele como não pode passar olha vem para
aqui tenta passar não consegue eu gosto
da escada porque ela fala comigo quando
eu me sinto sozinha olha olha lá falar
aqui ó
e é porque a escada é nova então quando
nós tivemos às vezes ela subia eu estou
sozinho em casa com os últimos adoramos
a companhia da escada
eu gosto de zouk para de roer o sofá
a suzuki está moto ficou ontem à noite
nós fomos jantar fora e ele não foi
jantar fora não fui comer nada não é
se não queres a comida ingrato aqui
temos a cozinha onde podemos cozinhar
bolos para que esta quinta-feira a lei
vamos ninguém nós estamos aqui há mais
ou menos cinco dias e eu tenho que essa
pizza tem que saber que essa fita tá a
planta segredo é segredo é
e ninguém não o meu não ponhas aí fruta
isso vai produzir um amigo seu lado nós
e aí
eu não perguntei ontem à noite nunca lhe
falte a cozinha deste nunca nunca porque
eu faço outras coisas que eu tenho eu
tenho atrás eu tenho outras
responsabilidades eu acho que é tua vez
o que ela assim então assim ele não quer
limpar a cozinha ele pede à noite então
faz o calisto ele é mais ou menos isso
então não não é verdade tem que ser a
porrada não não de cereais
e lá no teu quarto não eu não como eu
não como doar tu leva o estudo folga não
não gostei dos dois anos na neve três
lixo debaixo da cama é que tá o sumo de
laranja fofinho de laranja nosso laranja
que levaram eu tenho plantas não haja
melhor netflix
é calúnia a questão agora é quem é quem
é
e aí
um pokémon go
o ok pessoal eu acho que para vocês
conseguirem ter acesso lá em cima para
vocês conseguirem ver tem que deixar
muito like aqui neste vídeo porque nós
vamos revelar ok mas ainda tá bloquear
aí não dá ainda não dá uma contagem de
likes aqui neste e são quantos litros é
pa no mínimo 30 mil sim são três quartos
já estou a base falar disso três quatro
30 mil dez mil quarto porque eu tenho
querer o quarto dele então pode inventar
uma grande confusão aqui em casa a um
sumo de laranja desaparecido
misteriosamente desaparecido na sua
barriga já não não tá na minha posso
passar as novidades então acho que eu
sou segura aí embaixo no primeiro link
vocês vão ter o meu segundo canal é
verdade eu vou fazer o segundo canal é o
dark frame 2.0 e o que é que nós vamos
fazer nesse canal eu vou já explicar
aqui para vocês subscreveram uma bom
aqui nesse canal eu vou começar a
e vocês pedem com regularidade que é um
como testar um amigo como é que está um
jogador de lol pranks coisas mais
elaboradas e não segundo canal eu vou
também fazer aquele fáceis pedem muito
mas que eu não quero muito fazer aqui
neste canal porque se não é uma mistura
de conteúdos e eu não quero muito fazer
tenho nada a ver nada a ver então nesses
quando canal eu vou fazer jogos de
terror como vocês pedem lá como eu fazia
2015 a paz é uma coisa que eu também
adoro eu assisto muito estou sempre ao
teu lado e eu pensei em fazer vídeos
também vou fazer isso lá o que é que eu
vou fazer mais e vou fazer outros tipos
de vídeos que não se enquadra muito bem
com este canal ok eu vou fazer tipo um
experiências outros tipos de conteúdo
portanto parcelar a pessoa vai ser assim
um conteúdo de completamente aleatório
mas vai ser bem divertido e eu vou
tentar ser regular mais nesse segundo
canal do que propriamente de neste este
aqui eu vou tentar colocar tipo uns três
vídeos
a pizza com canela está aqui em baixo
vou tentar colocar um vídeo por dia
porque está como solventes mais simples
mais rápidos de serem editados mais
rápido serem feitos eu vou colocar o
vídeo por dia então é só passar lá e por
já estarem pessoal subscrevam vou fazer
isso também com a voz misteriosa isso
tudo correr bem aqui nesse segundo canal
pessoal ainda vão lançar um terceiro o
canal exclusivamente com o pe fique
atento subir também vai lançar o segundo
canal portanto estes dois canais
secundários derem certo nós ainda vamos
fazer o terceiro em conjunto com um
conteúdo muito louco tanto aplique se
inscrevam deixa o like para gostosa
vamos ter que fazer aí uns como evitar
namorada e como acessar a namorada isso
talvez alguns ação que
e da visualização tu és muito fácil de
ser assustada não és bastante irritante
vai ter graça vai vai gostar eles vão
gostar obrigatoriamente posso digitar
agora já muito fácil não é
e para para na nós temos o papá é muito
fácil só quiser eu como editar a
namorada comentem também e é isso até
logo suzuki despertar isso aqui tchau
zouk e
ah ah eu faço é isso não valeu